Pixar just made history with its first
gay lead character the animated Pixar
Disney Plus short follows Greg who is
not out as he moves to a city to live
with his boyfriend most coming-out
stories are not easy and neither is
Greg's Greg's parents show up
unannounced at his new apartment to help
with the move
doing here I don't know you gotta go
I'll call you later okay tell them he
thinks it's so easy just look them in
the eyes and say mom dad I'm this is my
boyfriend now it's a short film it's
only 9 minutes so I don't want to give
too too much away but I will say it is
incredibly heartwarming and I do hope
everybody watches this film it also
proves that things are moving in the
right direction with animation finally
reflecting our current society which of
course includes LGBTQ individuals
earlier this year the Disney Pixar film
onward also included an LGBTQ reference
lean awaits character Spectre mentions
her girlfriend it's not easy being a new
parent my girlfriend's daughter can we
pull my hair out okay oh and last year
fans started speculating online that
Elsa from the frozen franchise could
actually be gay the internet named her a
queer icon I love it can you imagine in
frozen 3 if Elsa came out it's not an
idea I'm ready to let go so did you
watch out what did you think of the
short have you seen on word yet great
movie do you think Elsa could be gay let
me know in the comments below
oh hey there if you want more LGBTQ news
and exclusive interviews click Subscribe
or watch these videos